a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono va dj oggi stiamo su parkour
curda la trama è bellissima c'è un gatto
che tra l'altro un figo della madonna
che cazzo fa ho provato sto gioco un
attimino per riuscire a capire una cosa
tipo né mi è morto il gatto la iniziato
no 30 secondi già è morto fantastico
siccome si chiama parkour che il parkour
penso lo conosciate tutti lo fa anche
mia nonna nel tempo libero
i ragazzi nella mia vita non ho mai
visto un gatto più figo di mario può
fare delle cose insomma dovrà
raccogliere 30 monete che sarebbero
quelle perfetta altro sono nemo detto e
gatto bellissimo mi devo buttare giù
delle cose di porto s che è successo
perché mi sto inglobando un bicchiere
che il bello di ragazzi provo a saltare
sulla sedia brown non lo so belli il
salto più bello della vita bello bel mi
piace questa cosa che ho fatto che quasi
ci sono dei miglioramenti camminate
anche da ole ragazzi sta cosa è una
fiducia io ci prende gusto peggiori al
si giochi capitemi che so no non e
monetari del ridendo e scherzando sono
un fenomeno
cos'è sta cosa clay miglior box usa
yours ad entrare dentro le scatole si
può in tracia cosa perché ma se i
ragazzi la madonna mosse tecniche
proprio poi mi spiegate perchè i
bicchieri si è un nuovo supereroe questo
siamo ritornati al punto di prima quindi
senza problemi lo capiamo native sui
fornelli ad adesso in avanti al posto
della prova del cuoco c'è un gatto ai
fornelli stecche di getto a tutto andare
poi qualcuno mi spiega come cazzo fa un
gatto a rimanere sospeso nel vuoto così
tipiche mi stava sul culo il bicchiere
abbiate pazienza c'è un free è successo
ha avuto uno spasmo fatemi capire
perfetto e lahm a caso prova ben dai
tanto ormai non mi stupisco più di che
cosa sa fare il suo gatto perché a prove
tirare testate al soffitto a su quello
ci lavoriamo
allora io devo buttare devo buttare in
teoria giu dei vasi che dovrebbero
essere non lo so perché sono morto ogni
tanto mi muore agli attori che non c'è
verso a fatica ok
mi piace bob atalanta roma proprio tanta
roba
devo buttare giù i vasi ma che beh
allora io ragazzi dovete capire che se
per caso avete un gatto e lo chiamate fa
vjc avete nel culo ma prova a
prescindere ogni tanto però muore ma
questa resta un difetto di fabbrica mi
collassa al gatto non è colpa mia mi
spiegato è quella sarebbe una
televisione si può salire cosa che
società dietro
sì adesso questa mela spiegate no perché
non ci sto capendo neanche i nomi
ragazzi ma allora voi voi lo sapete che
io di giochi ne ho provati tanti questo
lo sapete ma è mai possibile arrivare a
steve iniziative ad esso ragazzi
farò il gatto antennista perché è mio
hobby e stan tennista anzi ignobile
ficcarmi dentro le antenne proprio
dentro lo sapevi sopra che devo fare la
devo fare si no
dove sono dovesse un film perché
ammettetelo ragazzi avete avete sognato
tutti almeno una volta nella vita di
vedere il vostro gatto così cena è una
cosa molto seria questa ragazzi le mie
doti le mie doti della minkia arrivare
lassù e mi la vedo durissima procedura
si è fatto è fatto un ciclo ariano qua
mi vedo malissimo si può andarci fari
seriamente il nostro gioco quanto e film
mi sa che ha detto fatto salire le scale
no perché è mezz'ora che tipo salgo con
un cazzo di ragno piegato però mi sa che
mi conviene più andar così perché se non
faccio un metro che tipo di qua si apra
la porta la brano perché non mi stupirei
tanto sa fare di tutto a piano
ho appena fatto prince of persia sud i
muri non mi faccio domande non ho capito
bene dove dovrebbero essere sti quadri
però sono morto
lo butta oggi credo di aver trovato il
quadro legame l'ha ricordato un po
diverso è però si fatemi arrivare un
attimo ok io faccio questo persa sui
muri ormai piano bravo ragazzo
oddio che casa tutti hanno un gatto
demonia per chi è che non ce la possono
programmare il quadro per favore gr
certo con la mia zampina di merda ho
fatto così e ovviamente si è squarciato
tutto ok
l'altro ridendo e scherzando la castro
fine lo sto finendo e ci sono se riesco
a finire sto gioco voglio voglio un
gatto in regalo proprio l altro tutti i
sestieri adattamenti gattini ai quadri
sono fantastici 4 quasi da spaccare però
secondo me li sto facendo più belli di
quanto non lo fossero prima e io non
vorrei dire bello ha una mira che marco
mia nonna credo fatemi arrivare allora
come faccia diversa
tenterò ragazzi di fare una cosa avrei
tentato di fare una cosa però sono morto
voglio arrivare là sopra la gara non so
se riesco ma ci prova 321 ragazzi ho
capito come sia allora forse si se ci ho
fatto l'ho fatto son salito su tutto
soffermava non avete idea delle ore per
salire cosa ragazzi sto gioco mi ricorda
troppo non lo so perché ma mi coda
trovato in storia gente sta ritto se
tipo piccolissima e le robe sono giganti
se non morisse ogni 4 fottuti secondi
melo ricorderebbe ancora di più la no
non è possibile c'è chi puzza la mamma
devo arrivare lassù ce la posso fare
lega apr che cosa hai fatto
sì se no tua madre la sua madre l'ho
vista ieri in autostrada se il ragazzo
goden no non ci crederò mai basta ho
vinto tutto
ce lo fa ci ho messo anni per tornare
quando ce la faccia andando alla sopra
che si mangia ma se magari facessi un
salto meno da rincoglionito piano
ma perché non salta su gatto di ragazzi
ho avuto un'idea geniale fermi un attimo
fermi un attimo
sì sì sì ok la florida ragazzi ho
praticamente finito se non fosse per
ecco come si faccia minchiam a dirlo
subito
ma chi cazzo l'aveva mi manca
praticamente due cose in croce se che
poi bellissimo che l'ombra in basso c'è
il gatto che cammina a caso sembra che
stia volteggiando vabbè adesso qualcuno
comunque mi mi deve spiegare atta a
quest'ultimo penso che lo devo fare a
caso perché non ci arrivo si no minchia
stavo calmissimo non così
ma poiché si no sì sì però dio santo car
[Musica]
minchia vi levo lucidare cazzo di gatto
monna lisa che brutta che sei pony manca
un quadro che quello là sopra 2 fottuti
vasi che sono quelli e due fottute
monete che sono quelle può avere tipo di
calamità per i giochi che fanno
incazzare dove ci sono i gatti non lo so
perché di gioco sempre giochi che mi
fanno incazzare dove ci sono i gatti ce
ne sara tipo una sorta di masochismo ci
siamo ragazzi
stavo cadendo in modo bruttissima ok so
come ho fatto a salvarvi visto che sto
volteggiando ma 5 allora mi mancano
non avevo visto che era finito il
lampadario porco lampadario anni perché
butto giù un quadro il che non sarebbe
neanche tanto strano ma qual è il
disagio mentale del creatore di questo
videogioco di precede no perché ancora
non l'ho capito inerte con poco ci siamo
mancano no no dovevo saltare il piano
piano un cazzo io sento se bloccato
ascolta che so già che stavo costa
bottiglia mi devo incassare [ __ ]
tue la bottiglia mi manca questo vaso
qui sotto se riuscissi a beccarlo magari
sarebbe un ok non lo prendo ragazzina
lelio devo buttare giù questo coso che
ciò sotto il culo per riuscire a vincere
ma non ce la farò invece si aspetta ce
l'ho fatta ho vinto social non c'è
neanche la scritta ringraziamento di
merda vinto e barazza di cuore per
questa bellissima partita appare parkour
e cioè ragazzine che posso concludere
che secondo stanza strano perché io
giochi con del disagio mi faccio spesso
ieri mandare affanculo prima mi sono
fatto braccio rosso ma va bene che posso
concludere che i ragazzi servito vi è
piaciuto ma setaccio documento mi piace
se anche voi avete un gatto avete un
amico che è un gatto che fa ste cazzate
hashtag il mio gatto è un figo della
madonna e non penso che ci sia un gatto
molto più fico di queste se ne vorresti
discreti lì ci vediamo un prossimo vito
bella ragazzi